you're about to learn about opengl from
victor gordon he has created an
excellent course for beginners
with simple to follow instructions and
informative diagrams
welcome to this beginner's course on
opengl if you're wondering what opengl
is well it's a cross-platform graphics
api
that allows you to render 3d and 2d
scenes
with the power of your graphics card
usually when programming we use our cpus
which
are great at doing a huge variety of
tasks one after another
in a linear fashion but when we deal
with graphics
a lot of the tasks are very similar and
don't usually depend on one another
so the fastest way to get a result would
be by doing
all of them at the same time in parallel
this is what gpus
or graphics cards excel at opengl is
simply a way for us to communicate with
the gpu
by the end of this course you'll be able
to import basic 3d models such as
this into your application and have a
firm grip on the basic concepts
of computer graphics everything from
basic buffers
used to send data to the gpu to classic
lighting algorithms and shaders the only
things you should be familiar
with before we start are the basics of
the c plus plus programming language and
the basics of visual studio
since thus the ide will be working with
the first thing you'll want to do is to
check you have the latest drivers for
your graphics card
and the latest version of visual studio
next make sure you download the 64-bit
windows installer for
cmake and go ahead with the installation
now download the source package for glfw
lastly you need to download glad make
sure you select
c c plus plus version 3.3
core ignore everything else and press
the generate button
now press on the glad.zip to download it
once you've finished installing cmake in
visual studio
open up visual studio and click on
create new project
select empty project for c plus click
next
type in a name for your project make
sure the check box is
checked and remember in what folder
you've placed your project
open up the folder of your project and
create a new folder
naming it libraries now we'll create
another two folders in libraries naming
them
lib and include this is where we later
import all our libraries into
now we need to extract the glfw zip file
and open up
cmake in cmake select the folder we've
just extracted as the source folder
then create a new folder named build in
the source folder and select it as the
build folder
now click on configure and after making
sure you have the same settings as me
click finish
now again make sure you have the same
configuration as me
and click on configure again click on
generate
and once everything is done exit from
cmake
now we want to build glfw so open up the
folder you've extracted
then build then open up glf glfw.sln
in visual studio right click here and
select
build solution if this gives you any
errors
it probably means that you've messed
around with the build and we'll just
have to regenerate
glfw using cmake and follow this step
again once your build finished
successfully
exit from visual studio
now it's finally time to import our
libraries in
so open up the glfw extracted folder and
go into build
source then debug and i'll cut and paste
glf3.lib into your lib folder that's
inside your libraries folder
back to the extracted glfw folder going
to include
cutting and pasting glfw into the
include folder of your project
assuming you followed the steps
correctly you can now delete the
extracted glfw folder and open up
glad.zip open up
include and extract the two folders into
your project's include folder
now go folder back and open up source
extracting glab.c
into your project's main folder we'll
now configure
our visual studio project to know where
to access the libraries from
so open up your project and make sure
you have 64-bit selected
now go to project properties and select
all platforms for your platform then go
to vc
plus plus directories open up include
directories and point to the include
folder
in your libraries folder
click ok and now do the same for your
library directories
with your lib folder
once you're done with that go to linker
input
and open up additional dependencies here
we'll write
glfw3.lib and opengl32.lib
don't worry even though it's called
opengl 32
it's still the 64-bit version is just
the naming convention
now click ok and ok the last thing you
have to do is to drag the glad.c file
from your project folder into your
source files folder in visual studio
then right-click source files click add
new item
select c plus plus file name it main.cpp
and click on add now in order to test
that everything is fine
include this and type int main
brackets curly brackets return 0
semicolon and run if you've done
everything correctly you should get no
errors
so now we're gonna pick up where we left
off and create a window
we're gonna use glfw to do that so the
first thing we need to do
is initialize it so we can properly use
its functions
and since we've initialized it we should
also terminate it before the function
ends so
i'll add this at the end of the function
now
glxw doesn't really know what version of
opengl we're using so we need to tell it
that
we can do that by giving it so-called
hints
with a special function that takes a
type of hint
and a value for example here i'm giving
it a hint
that we are going to specify the major
version
of opengl that we are using and then i
give it
the version itself which is three
since we are using opengl 3.3
now i'm just gonna do the same for the
minor version
which is the exact same one
the last hint we have to give it is
about which opengl
profile we want to use so i'll type
glfw underscore opengl underscore
profile now an opengl profile
is sort of like a package of functions
as
far as i know there are only two
packages
core which contains all the modern
functions
in compatibility which contains both the
modern
and outdated functions we only care
about the modern ones
so i'm gonna use the core profile
now for the window itself this is the
data type of a window
object in glfw let's just name it window
and use the create a window function
this will take
five inputs the width of the window
the height of the window the name
of the window
whether we want it full screen or not
which we do not
and the last thing is not important
and just to be on the safe side i'll add
a bit of error checking
in the case in which the window fails to
create
so great we now have a window object
problem is glfw isn't the brightest kid
around the block
so i'll now have to tell him that since
we've created the window
we would also like to use it who would
have thought
this tells glfw to make the window part
of the
current context a context being a sort
of
object that holds the whole of opengl
it's a bit abstract as context can hold
and do many things but we'll just go
with this for now
now just like before once we are done
with the window itself
we want to delete it so let's do that at
the end of the main
function if you run the program now
you'll maybe be able to spot a window
pop up
and instantly disappear into oblivion
that happens because once the main
function finishes
creating the window it just continues to
go about its business
and tries to reach the end of itself
which when it does
it ends the whole program in order to
stop that from happening
we need to make a while loop which will
only end
on the condition that the window should
close
that condition will only happen when we
press the close button
or if another function tells the window
to close
and now just one more thing before we
get our glorious window
we need to tell glfw to process all the
pulled events
such as the window appearing being
resized and
other such things if we don't process
those events
the window will just be in a state of
not responding
and now press run and watch the fruits
of your labor
but i find this white window kind of
boring
so let's add some color to it
we'll start doing that by finally using
glad
and telling him to load the needed
configurations
for opengl then we'll
tell opengl the viewport of our window
which is just the
area of the window we want opengl to
render in
that will go from the bottom left corner
of the window
coordinates 0 0 to the top right corner
of the window
coordinates 800 800 in
our case now in order to go forward
i'll have to introduce some computer
graphics concepts
so lesson time yay
as you probably already know screens
display a
bunch of images really really fast which
give us the illusion of motion
these images are called frames screens
display frames by changing from the
pixels
of the display to the pixels of a frame
these are changed
one by one from the top left of the
screen to the bottom right of the screen
now while the screen is loading the
pixels from the current frame and
displaying them the next frame
is being written in the background away
from our eyes
once the screen finishes displaying the
current frame
it switches it with the next frame and
starts displaying dot
well in the background the no previous
frame
is being overwritten with new
information these two frames
are called buffers and they're simply a
space of storage in memory
for pixels the buffer from which
information is being read
to be displayed on the screen is called
the front buffer
while the other one on which information
is being written
is called the back buffer now
let's write the actual code we're going
to tell opengl to
prepare to clear the color of a buffer
and give it another color
i'm going to give it a nice navy blue in
the normalized decimal rgb
form of color and set the last number
the alpha to one the alpha number
dictates the transparency of the color
one being
opaque and zero being completely
transparent
now we want opengl to execute the
command we've told it to prepare for
so we'll use this function specifying we
want to use the command on the color
buffer
we'll learn more about types of buffers
in the next video
so at this point we have a back buffer
with the color we want and the front
buffer with the default color
so in order to see our color we'll want
to swap the buffers
since only the pixels on the front
buffer are being displayed
now press run in tada we now have a
nicely colored window
that you can show off to your imaginary
friends
and the last thing that's left to do is
just to write some comments so that you
can make sure you understand what's
happening
try writing them with your own words but
if you find that difficult
then feel free to copy mine i'll leave
the source code in the description
and the pdf with some exercises so you
can practice what you've just learned
so now let's add a triangle to the mix
but first
i'll have to introduce you to something
called the graphics pipeline
the graphics pipeline is essentially
just a series of functions which take
some data at the beginning
and then at the very end of the graphics
pipeline it outputs a frame
now the input is called the vertex data
this is just an array of well vertices
though they're not mathematical vertices
since each vertex
besides having a position also contains
other data such as
color or texture coordinates
the first phase of the graphics pipeline
is called the vertex shader
the vertex reader takes the positions of
all the vertices
and transforms them or if you want to it
can keep them the exact same way
your choice once all the transformations
are done the shape assembler takes all
the positions
and connects them according to a
primitive but what's a primitive i hear
you asking
well a primitive is just a shape such as
a
triangle or maybe a point or a line
each primitive interprets the data
differently
for a triangle it would take three
points and then draw a triangle between
them
whereas a line would take two points at
a time
and draw lines between them up next we
have the geometry shader
which can add vertices and then create
new primitives out of already existing
primitives
but this one is a bit more complex so we
won't be seeing it for a long while
next comes the rasterization phase where
all the perfect mathematical shapes get
transformed into
actual pixels so what before was a
perfect mathematical triangle now
becomes just a bunch of pixels which are
just
kind of a bunch of squares but these
pixels
don't really have any color to them so
here comes the fragment shader
which is one of the most important
shaders so the fragment shader adds
colors to the pixels
these depend on many many things such as
the lighting
or the textures or shadows
at this point you might have multiple
colors for just
one pixel because of multiple objects
overlapping
so that's fixed in the last phase as is
the blending of transparent objects
into the final color now for the actual
coding
so sadly opengl doesn't provide us with
defaults for the vertex
in fragment shaders so we'll have to
write our own
but since this tutorial doesn't focus on
the shaders themselves but
rather the overarching process of using
the shaders
i'll simply copy paste the shader scene
don't worry though
i'll be looking at those in a future
tutorial
so first let's specify the coordinates
of our vertices
for now we're going to work in 2d so
we're going to ignore the z-axis
as for the x and y axis well their
origin
is located in the middle of the window
with x pointing to the right
and y pointing up now the coordinate
system is normalized
which means that the leftmost part of
the window for x
is negative one and the rightmost part
of the window for
x is positive one while for y
the lowermost part of the window is
negative one and the uppermost part of
the window is positive one
so now i'll make an array of data type
gl
float why gel float well you would
probably use
normal floats but these may differ in
size from the floats that opengl
uses so it's just safer to go with the
opengl version
there is a link down in the description
to a wikipedia page
where you can see all the data types
that opengl has
now i'll just name these vertices and
add some coordinates
now in this array every three floats
will represent
one coordinate i'll first add the
coordinate
of the left corner then the right corner
and then the top corner this may look
kind of complicated but that's because i
chose
nice coordinates such that i get an
equilateral triangle
but you can put any coordinates you want
to as long as they are between negative
one and positive one
so great now we have three coordinates
so let's just fit them into the graphics
pipeline and get a nice triangle
well sadly it's not that easy we may
have the source code
for our vertex shader and our fragment
shader
but we don't have the shaders themselves
so
shaders are an opengl object and these
are
just kind of like in the background in
the memory
and we can only access them by
references
aka value in fact all opengl
objects are accessed by a reference keep
that in mind
as it is very important so let's create
the value aka a reference
to store our vertex shader in so
i'll type in g l i g-l-u-i-n-t
which is the opengl version of an
unsigned integer
aka a positive integer i'll name it
vertex shader and use
gl create shader to create the shader
and get the reference value
and as an input you'll have to specify
what kind of shader you want in this
case we want the vertex shader
so now that we have a vertex shader
let's feed it the
source code we copy pasted earlier we'll
use
gl shader source and the first thing
we're going to give it is the reference
value
then we're going to specify that we're
only using one string
for the whole shader then we're going to
point to the source code
and then the last thing doesn't matter
just write null now the thing is that
the gpu can't understand
the source code so we'll have to compile
it right now
into machine code so i'll just use gl
compile shader
and give it the reference value so great
now we have a vertex shader
so not just do the exact same thing for
the fragment shader only replace
everywhere you see vertex with fragment
if you get lost just check my code now
in order to
actually use both of these shaders we'll
have to wrap them up into something
called a shader program
so just like before let's create a
reference value name it shader program
and use geocreate program this time not
specifying anything else because they're
just
one type of shader program and to attach
a shader to the shader program
you're gonna use gl attach shader first
plugging in
the reference to the shader program then
plugging in the reference to the
shader itself once you've finished
attaching your shaders
we want to wrap up the shader program
we're going to use geo link program for
that and we're just going to pass it in
the shader program reference and just to
keep it tidy i'm now gonna delete the
shaders we've created before because
they're already in the program itself
so great now we're done with the shaders
so you would be tempted to press
run but nothing is gonna happen because
we haven't done anything with our
vertices
we haven't even told opengl how to
interpret them
so let's do that now so sending stuff
between the cpu
and the gpu is kind of slow so when you
do send stuff you want to send it into
big batches
these big batches are called buffers do
not confuse them with the front and back
buffers from the last tutorial though
so let's create a vertex buffer object
where we'll store
our vertex data and as always we're
gonna use a reference
integer for it now the vbo is
actually an array of references but
since we only have one object we only
need one
so for now we're just gonna leave it
like this
we can create the buffer object by using
gl
gen buffers and giving it one as the
first argument
because we only have one 3d object
and then pointing it to the reference
now let me introduce you to the concept
of binding
binding in opengl means that we make a
certain object
the current object and whenever we fire
a function that would modify
that type of object it modifies the
current object
aka the binded object so now i'll just
bind it using gl bind buffer and giving
it
gel array buffer and the reference of
the vbo now i used
gl array buffer because that's the type
we need to use
for the vertex buffer if you want to see
the other types of buffers
i left a link in the description to the
opengl documentation
where you can look up this function and
it will tell you what other kinds of
buffers
there are now let's actually store
our vertices in the vbo we'll do that by
using
gel buffer data we first specify the
type of buffer
the total size of the data in bytes we
can just use a c plus
function to get that and now we give the
actual
data itself so the vertices and
finally we specify the use of this data
this is done by typing gl underscore and
now
we choose between stream static and
dynamic
stream means that the vertices will be
modified once
and used a few times static means that
the vertices
will be modified once induced many many
times
and dynamic means that the vertices will
be modified multiple times
and used many many times you need to
specify these in order to
improve performance so now we continue
with another underscore and again
choose between draw read and copy
draw means that the vertices will be
modified and be used to draw an image on
the screen
and you can imagine what the other two
do so
great now we have a nicely packed object
with our vertex data
but opengl doesn't know where to even
find it
in order to do that we make use of
another object called a vertex array
object
this source pointers to one or more vbos
and tells opengl how to interpret them
vios exist in order to quickly be able
to switch between different
vbos so let's go back and put vao
in front of vbo now let's generate the
vio using
gl gen vertex arrays seeing that we only
have one object
and pointing to the vao reference make
sure you generate the vio before
the video the ordering is very important
now let's find the vao so that we can
work with it
now let's configure it so that opengl
knows how to read the vbo
we'll do that by using the function gl
vertex attribute pointer
first we pass the index of the vertex
attribute we want to use
a vertex attribute is a way of
communicating with a vertex shader from
the
outside i'll talk more about this in the
tutorial for shaders
the first input is going to be the
position of the vertex attribute which
in our case is zero
the next input is how many values we
have per vertex
in our case that's three because we have
three floats
next we're going to tell what kind of
values we have we just have floats
now the next input only matters if we
have the
coordinates as integers but we don't
have that so
just write in gl underscore false now we
have to give the stride of our vertices
which is just the amount of data between
each vertex
in our case since we have three floats
then that is just
three times the size of one float and
the last thing is called the offset
which is a pointer to where our vertices
begin in the array
but since our vertices begin right at
the start of the array
we're gonna give this weird pointer void
so finally we've configured the vertex
attribute
now in order to use it we need to enable
it using
gl enable vertex attribute array and
give it 0 because that's the position of
our vertex
attribute now this next step is not
mandatory
but it's nice to have just so you can be
100 sure you won't accidentally change a
vba
or vio with a function we basically just
combined both the vbo and voa by binding
to zero
now once again make sure you have the
same ordering of your functions as i do
in the case of the vao in vbo because
the ordering is
extremely important and just to keep
everything nice and clean let's go to
the end of our main function
and delete all the objects we've created
so far
and now just a few more lines of code
and we'll finally have a triangle
first copy and paste the gel clear color
and gel clear functions into the while
loop
now let's activate the shader program
we've created like a thousand years ago
and now let's bind the vio so that we're
telling opengl that we want to use
this one it's not really necessary to do
this because we only have one object in
one
video but it's good to get used to this
now for the drawing function itself
we're going to use gel draw arrays
specifying the type of primitive we want
to use triangles in our case
the starting index of the vertices 0 in
our case
and then the amount of vertices we want
to draw since we're drawing one triangle
and a triangle has three vertices
that's three and last but not least we
make sure
we swap the buffers so that the image
gets updated each frame
and finally after a long long journey
we can finally press run and see a nice
triangle
pop up now i can imagine you probably
feel a bit overwhelmed
by the amount of information you just
got
don't worry though it's normal i was
also a bit overwhelmed by it at the
beginning
so now a good way to make sure you
understand most things
is to add comments to all the steps and
functions and
rewatch certain parts that you don't
fully understand yet
if you want to know more about
individual functions simply look them up
in the documentation of opengl
it helps more than you'd expect so as
always
i've left a link in the description to a
pdf with exercises for you to do
exercising and messing around with the
functions really helps you learn what
each of them does
so now we're going to build on top of
that by introducing the concept of
index buffers as you hopefully remember
we can draw a triangle by telling opengl
to use the triangle primitive
between three vertices in this case
vertices
0 1 and 2. easy enough right
but what about this case well here we
have three triangles
so that means we need nine vertices 0 1
2 3 4 five and six
seven eight but as you can probably see
we have duplicate vertices which means
that we're just wasting memory space
so let's rewrite the vertices but this
time without duplicates
so in this case we have vertices 0 1
2 3 4 and 5.
if we give this to opengl it will draw a
small upside down triangle
on top of a big triangle which is not
what we want in order to prevent that we
need to make use of an
index buffer an index buffer tells
opengl the order in which it should go
over vertices
here it first goes over 0 4
3 then 4 1 5
and then 3 5 2. we solve the problem of
duplicate vertices by simply visiting
the same vertices
twice using indices
so now let's actually implement this
i'll first add the new vertices to my
array
and now i'll create an array of data
type gl
uint for the indices and
type in the indices we saw previously
generating the index buffer
is very similar to the vertex buffer so
let's first create its reference value
next let's generate the reference value
and store it in
evo specifying we only have one object
in order to do something with it we need
to make it current
aka bind it and also specify
its of type gl element array buffer
now we link it to our indices array if
you don't know what these
inputs mean check out my previous
tutorial
now we unbind it but make sure you
unbind it
after you unbind your vao since the ebo
is stored
in the vao so if you unbind it before
unbinding the vao you're essentially
telling
opengl that you don't want the vao
to use your ebo and to keep things clean
we'll delete it at the end of the main
function
the last step is to replace gl draw
arrays
with gl draw elements specifying the
primitive we want to use
how many indices we want to draw the
data type
of our indices and the index of our
indices which in our case is zero
now just press run and enjoy your
triangles
as always i've left the source code and
some exercises in the description
now let's organize things a bit since as
you can see
we have a lot of stuff going on in here
let's start by moving the shaders into
their own separate text files
open up the solution explorer and create
a folder called
shaders in the resource files folder
now let's add a new item selecting
utility
then text file and naming it
default.word
open it up and copy paste the vertex
shader source code into it
make sure to get rid of the one variable
you have
and all the quotes and slash ends
now do the exact same thing for the
fragment shader
only name it default.frag instead of
default.vert
now let's create our very own shader
class
go to header files add new item
header file and name it shader class dot
h in this file we'll declare our class
and other functions related to it
first let's write hash if n d e f
shader class h hash define
shader class h hash and if
this lets c plus plus know not to open
up the file twice
since that would create variable clashes
now we'll need to declare a function
that will read the shader text files
i will not go through the details of it
though since the function itself
is irrelevant to opengl just know it
outputs the contents of a text file as a
string
now let's declare the shader class which
will simply be an opengl shader program
that's nicely wrapped up
give it a public id aka reference
declare a constructor that will take in
the shader source codes
and two functions activate and delete
once you're done with that go to source
files and create a cpp file
named shaderclass.cpp i'll start by
including
shaderclass.h and then copy pasting the
filereader function
link in the description to all the
source code
now let's write the shader constructor
first let's get the strings from the
text files
into two variables and then convert and
store them
into character arrays now we just need
to copy paste all the shader related
code from the main function
modifying it slightly by replacing
shader program with id
and changing vertex shader source to
vertex source
and fragment shader source to fragment
source
don't forget to also write the activate
and delete functions
by again copy pasting from the main
function
great we've made the shader class next
let's make a vertex buffer class
create a header vbo.h and include glad
for the opengl
functions now create a vbo class
giving it a public id variable and a
constructor that takes some vertices
in their sizing bytes the size of the
vertices
is in the gl size iptr data type
since that's what opengl uses for sizes
in bytes
now just add some declarations for the
bind unbind
and delete functions then create a c
plus plus file
vbo.cpp and copy paste the same
functions as me
changing the name of some variables such
as vbo2id
make sure to also copy paste in the code
for the other functions
now repeat the same procedures we've
done with the vbo
for the ebo making sure to replace
jill array buffer with gl element array
buffer
and now finally the vertex array class
create a header and include glad like
before but this time
also make sure to include vbo.h as we'll
need to link a vbo
to the vao create the vao
class give it a public id create a
constructor without any inputs
and then a link vbo function that will
take a vbo
and the layout which we'll learn more
about in the shaders tutorial
don't forget to declare the usual bind
unbind
and delete functions once you're done
with that
create the vao.cpp file and include the
vao header
now copy paste in the relevant functions
but make sure to bind and
unbind the vbo in the link vbo function
make sure you've written everything the
same way i did
great now we're done with creating all
the classes all that's left to do now
is to go back to the main function
include all the headers we've created
and replace all the default functions we
had with the new functions and classes
i'll also move the vertices and indices
to the top of the file as i think it
looks better
if you press run everything should work
just like before
as always the final step is to add your
own comments in order to
make sure you understand all of this if
you run
into any problems the source code is in
the description
now let's finally learn more about
shaders you can think of shaders as
functions that run on the gpu since they
are similar to functions
they can take inputs and also have
outputs
so let's take a look at our default
vertex shader
while looking at this you might think
it's c code but
it's actually opengl shading language
aka
glsl which has a similar syntax to c
the first line contains the version of
glsl we are using
since we have opengl 3.3 we need to use
glsl
330. the second line takes an input apas
using the layout with location 0.
layouts help opengl
with the vertex data it receives in this
case
we say that on the zeroth layout there
is a vectory
data type for positions now for the main
function
we simply assign gl position of eq4
with all our positions plus an arbitrary
one for the fourth dimension
which we can ignore for now opengl
recognizes the keyword gl
position and knows it needs to use it as
the position for the vertex
you can think of this shader as
outputting gel position
even though it doesn't specifically do
that
on the other hand the fragment shader
specifically says on the second line
that it outputs a vic 4 color
now for the main function we simply gave
it a color in rgba
format to use for all the vertices
but instead of having one color for all
the points
let's give each vertex its own color
so i'll start by writing rgb values
after each position in the vertices
array
then i'll add a second layout with
location 1
that takes a vector named a color
but since the fragment shader is the
shader that takes care of colors
we need to output the colors from the
vertex shader
to the fragment shader to do that i'll
output a vectory named
color and in the main function make it
equal to the a color
imported from the vertices array now
in the fragment shader i'll input the
exact same
vectory named color it's very
important to give inputs and outputs
the same name since otherwise opengl
wouldn't know to make the link between
them in the first place
and the final step for this shader is to
make frag color
equal to color since that's what we are
outputting
now we should configure the vertex
attribute pointers
but first we need to modify a function
from the vao class
let's change link vbo to link atrib
and add four variables num components
type stride and offset
now do the same in the vao.cpp file
and add in the new variables as inputs
to the gel
vertex attribute pointer just like me
so we are sending the shader an array of
a bunch of bytes in order for opengl
to know how to interpret all of them we
tell it how to do so
in the gel vertex attribute pointer
function
first we specify the layout location
in our case 0 for coordinates
slash position and 1 for color
then the number of components per layout
3 in both of our cases
then the type of our components gl
float and finally the stride in
offset the stride is the distance in
bytes between the beginning of one
vertex
and the end of another which in our case
is six times the size of a float since
each vertex has six floats
the offset is simply the initial offset
of a layout in bytes for the coordinates
that's
zero because they are right at the
beginning
well for the colors the offset is three
times the size of a float in bytes
since the first three components are
coordinates
now let's write all of this in code by
linking the
attribute for coordinates and colors
from our vbo
to our vao now if you press
run you should see that the triangles
have a nice
gradient of color you might be asking
yourself why there is a gradient of
colors
even though we only specified a couple
of colors
well that's because if a primitive has
different colors for its
vertices then opengl will automatically
create a nice gradient
from one color to another this is called
interpolation and it is used in other
things
besides colors as well now let's look at
the second method
of getting inputs and outputs within
and outside of a shader this second
method
makes use of uniforms uniforms are
sort of like universal variables that
can be
accessed by other shaders and can
even be accessed from within the main
function
of the program without the use of a vao
let's create a float uniform called
scale
in our vertex shader now let's just
add to each coordinate the corresponding
coordinate
multiplied by the scale what this
essentially does
is it increases the size of our
triangles
so if the scale is let's say 0.5
then our triangles are 50 bigger
one thing to note though is that you
should
never declare uniforms if you're not
going to use them
since otherwise opengl will delete them
automatically
and that may cause errors okay
now in order to give the uniform a value
we must first get its reference value in
the main function
we'll do that by using gel get uniform
location
and store the reference in an opengl
unsigned
integer variable called unid
the function will take us inputs the
reference of the shader program
and the name of the uniform now in order
to give it a value
we must use the gl uniform function
but we can only do so after activating
our shadow program so make sure you
write it after
shaderprogram.activate gel uniform
is a bit of a weird function as its
name's
suffix changes depending on the data
type we are inputting
if you want to know all the variants of
the function look it up in the
documentation
i left in the description we are going
to use gel uniform one
f since we are only inputting one float
and then for the inputs we'll use the
uni
id and 0.5 f
now if you press run our triangles
should be bigger
as a final step i will add some error
checking in the shader class
since we don't have debugging for our
shaders and so it would be nice to get a
basic
error message when a shader fails to
compile
if you want to know how the error
functions work i left a link in the
description to a wikipedia article
on them don't forget to add comments to
everything to make sure you understand
what you've written
and as always the source code and some
exercises are left down in the
description
so now let's take a look at textures
textures can be one-dimensional
two-dimensional or three-dimensional but
in this tutorial we'll only look at the
two-dimensional textures as they're the
most common type of texture
so the first thing we'll want to do is
to import an image into our program so
that we can make it into a texture
and display it in order to do that we're
going to use this popular
open source library called sdb
to install it go to your project folder
then libraries
and then include now create a folder
named stb
and inside of it create a text file
named stb underscore image.txt
now go to the link i left in the
description press ctrl a to select
everything and then copy paste it into
the text file we've just created
make sure to save it and then rename it
to stb underscore image dot
h now create a cpp file named stb.cpp in
your project source files
and write the following into it so that
will only use the things we need from
this library
now right click the cpp file and click
on compile
make sure to only do this once that's it
now if you want to use the library
simply include the header file into the
file you want to use
it in i'll do that in the main.cpp file
now before we get to the texture let's
make sure we have the coordinates for a
square
so that we can better see our texture
when displayed
don't forget to also change your indices
and the gl
draw elements function run your program
to make sure you do indeed get a square
if everything is all right then let's
import our imaging
keep in mind that square textures in
powers of 2
such as 1024 by 1024 pixels
or 2048 by 2048 pixels
are better optimized than textures with
a random number of pixels
so do try to make them fit this format
i'll be using this
image of popcat that's 512 by
512 pixels which i'll put into a
textures folder
in resource files don't forget to also
put the image in your project's main
folder
first we have to create three integer
variables to store the width and height
of the image in pixels
and the number of color channels it has
then we'll store the image itself in an
unsigned character array
named white using the function sdbi
underscore load
and giving it the location and name of
the image
the pointers of the variables we created
and zero
that's it for importing it in easy right
now let's create the texture object
itself just like
any opengl object we'll first create a
reference variable of type jluint
and name it texture now just use gelgen
textures to generate the texture object
giving it the number of textures you
want one in our case
and the pointer to the reference
variable since we've created it we also
want to delete it at the end of the main
function
we now need to assign the texture to a
texture unit
you can think of texture units as slots
for textures
that come together as a bundle these
generally hold about 16 textures
and allow the fragment shader to work
with all 16 textures
at the same time to insert our texture
in the slot of a texture unit we simply
need to activate the texture unit we
want using gel activate texture
plugging in the index of the texture
unit and then binding our texture with
gel bind texture
inserting the texture type and its
reference value
since we now have our texture binded
that means that this would be a good
time to adjust its settings
to our liking first we'll have to choose
how we want our image to be processed
when scaled
up or down we can choose gel nearest
which keeps all the pixels
as they are this is preferred when
working with pixel alert
or we can choose gel linear which
creates new pixels
according to the pixels nearby this
generally results in a blurrier
image which one you choose depends on
your needs in a certain context
for now i'll just go with gel nearest
i'll use the gel text parameter i
function to tweak our texture settings
and input the type of our texture
the setting we want to modify and the
value we want to give our setting
i'll modify both the mean filter and mag
filter settings
now the second setting is how we want
our texture to be repeated
we can choose between gel repeat gel
mirrored repeat
gel clamp to edge and gel clamp to
border
the first one simply repeats the image
the second one
repeats the image but mirrors it every
time it repeats it
the third one stretches the borders of
the image and
the last one simply puts a flat color of
your choice outside the image
note that you can mix and match them
since they only apply on one
axis so you could have the texture
repeat on the vertical axis
but only have a flat color on the
horizontal axis
these axes are named str
corresponding to the common x y and z
axes just like before we'll use gel text
parameter i
plugging in the texture type the setting
we want to modify
and the value of our setting make sure
to do this for both the s
and t axes if you want to use dual clamp
to order you'll have to
also use gel text parameter fv
plugging in the texture type gel texture
border color
and the color of the border which should
be an array of
three or four floats now that our
settings are
complete we can generate the texture
using gel text image 2d
and inputting the following the type of
texture
0 the type of color channels we want the
texture to have
the width the height 0 this is just the
legacy left over thing
the type of color channels our image has
the data type of our pixels
and the image data itself the most
common types of color channels
are glrgb in glrgba
the first one is for jpegs and the
second one is for pngs if you want to
look at all the types of color channels
and pixel data types
i left a link in the description to the
opengl documentation
if at the end of this tutorial you get
an error during compiling
then it might be because you specify the
wrong type of color channels
or pixel data type for reading your
image
since we've already imported the image
data into the texture
we'll want to delete the data using sdbi
image free
and also unbind the texture so we don't
accidentally do something to it
the last thing you'll want to do after
that is to use the gl generate
mipmap function plugging in the data
type of the texture
this will generate the mipmaps for the
texture which are just smaller
resolution versions of the same texture
that are used when the texture is far
away for example
great we have the texture but we did not
specify how we want the texture to be
mapped on the vertices
so let's do that now by adding
coordinates to our vertices
the coordinates of the texture go from 1
to 0 on both
axis starting from the bottom left
corner
if you would give coordinates higher
than 1 then the texture will be repeated
such as
in this example now that we've modified
our vertices
we also need to add a new layout to our
vertex shader and make sure to modify
our vertex buffer object
since the fragment shader deals with
colors we need to export the texture
coordinates to the fragment shader
and import them like so the last thing
we need to do in the fragment shader
is to create a uniform of type sampler2d
call it 0 then equal the frac color to
the function
texture which takes text 0 and takes
coordinates as inputs
the uniform tells opengl which texture
unit
it should use so in the main function
create a uniform just like in the
shaders tutorial
and assign the uniform the index of our
slot
0 in this case make sure to do this
after you've activated the shader
program
the last thing we need to do is to bind
the texture object in the main
function and we're done if you press run
you should see a majestic texture appear
on your square
but wait it's upside down well that's
because
opengl reads images from the bottom left
corner
to the top right corner while sdb
reads them from the top left corner to
the bottom right corner
so all we have to do to fix this is to
write
sdbi said flip vertically on load true
before we load in the image file to wrap
it all up i will create a custom texture
class just like in tutorial number four
don't forget to add comments to
everything you've written so that you
can make sure you understand what's
happening
the source code and some exercises to
test your knowledge
are in the description as always
now let's finally leave the boring 2d
plane
and ascend to three dimensions but first
a little correction for my past videos
in the vio
and texture class i forgot to make the
vbo
and shader inputs references so just add
an and sign like so now for the main
part
as i have mentioned before opengl
restricts our coordinates to normalized
coordinates
so in order to bypass this and enrich
our coordinates with a wider range for
three dimensions we can contract and
expand the different coordinates using
matrices
if you don't know much about matrices
then you should still be able to
somewhat follow along
but i highly recommend you watch 301
bronze
linear algebra playlist first as it will
help you later down the line
in any case we'll be using this nice
little library
called glm for our matrices so go to
this website that's down in the
description and
click on download go to your libraries
folder then
include now open up the zip file go into
glm and now
extract the folder named glm into your
include folder
once that's done go to your project and
include the following parts of the
library
that's it we can now use matrices easy
all right theory time so in order to get
a nice 3d image in perspective we need
to apply different matrices to different
coordinates
let's take a look at these types of
coordinates first
we have the local coordinates these are
the coordinates whose origin
is the same as an object's origin
these are usually located at the center
of an object
but that's not always the case then we
have the world coordinates
whose origin is at the center of the
world
these coordinates usually contain the
location of other
objects next we have the view
coordinates which have the same origin
as a camera
or viewpoint notice that these do not
yet account for perspective perspective
is added in the next set of coordinates
which are the clip coordinates these are
essentially the same as the few
coordinates
except they clip aka delete any vertices
outside the normalized range
and can also account for perspective and
the final coordinates
are the screen coordinates where
everything is flattened out such that it
can be
viewed on your screen now in order to
move from a coordinate system to the
next
we make use of matrices there are three
main matrices we make use of
the model matrix which takes local
coordinates to world coordinates
the view matrix which takes world
coordinates to
view coordinates and the projection
matrix
which takes view coordinates to clip
coordinates
the final transformation from clip
coordinates to space coordinates is done
automatically all these matrices we are
applying
are 4d but we won't have to actually
write them ourselves
since glm can take care of that so let's
create the model matrix
we start by creating a variable called
model of type
math4 and equaling it to the identity
matrix
which is simply math4 1.0
this is called initialization and it
must be done
since otherwise the matrix is full of
zeros
and any transformation we would apply on
it would result in the same
empty matrix initialize the other two
matrices as well
the model matrix can remain ascites
since our
object is in the center of the world
coordinates and that's fine for now
but right now our camera is also in the
center
so we want to move back and also a bit
up
but it's not really us doing this but
the world itself
we are essentially moving the whole
world around us instead of
us moving around the whole world in any
case
to do this we are going to use the
function translate
plugging in our view matrix and the
vectory which will indicate in which
direction and how much to move the whole
world
let's just move it down 0.5 and forward
2.0
note that the z axis is positive towards
us and negative away from us and for the
projection matrix we'll use the
perspective function
plugging in the field of view in radians
the aspect ratio of our screen
and the closest and furthest point we
can see
in other words if something is closer
than 0.1 units to us
then it will be clipped and if it's
further away than 100.0 units
it will again get clipped you can see
this in games when you are sometimes
able to see through walls or
characters while bumping into them or
when objects disappear at far away
distances
notice that i've used the function
radians to transform my degrees into
radians
let's also create two variables for the
width and height
of our window so we can easily modify
them from now on
now all that's left to do is to import
these matrices into the vertex shader
we can of course do this by using
uniforms so let's
simply declare three uniforms of type
mod 4
and assign them values in the main
function like so
we first input their location then one
then gel
false since we don't want opengl to
transpose them
and finally we need to use the function
value ptr which we give the matrix to
this is done so that we can point to the
matrix object itself
not the data in it don't forget to have
the shader
activated before assigning these values
then go back to the vertex shader
and equal gel position to the projection
matrix
times the view matrix times the model
matrix
times a veg4 whose 3d coordinates are a
pos
and the fourth dimension is one now if
you run the program you'll notice that
things look different
though you can't really see the
perspective since the plane is flat
and parallel to us so let's make a
pyramid
i'll start by setting the coordinates
colors and texture coordinates
then the indices and finally i'll modify
the gel draw elements function
which i'll generalize like so so we
don't have to bother with it again
i'll also use this brick texture which
you can find in the description
now if you press run we should see our
pyramid
but sadly it just looks like a triangle
so let's make it spin so that we can see
it in its 3d glory
we simply have to apply the rotation
function to the model matrix
giving it the matrix we want to modify
the rotation in radians
and the axis we want to rotate it about
in this case
that would be straight up so y equals
one
then just create a simple timer that
will change the rotation by half a
degree
every 60th of a second if you press run
you should see the pyramid spinning
around
but you'll also probably notice some
weird glitches that's because we're not
telling opengl to account for the depth
of these triangles so it's unsure which
triangle to put on top of which
one to fix that we simply need to enable
depth testing once
using gel enable chill depth test and
when we clear the gel
color buffer bit we should also clear
the gel
div buffer bit and now we're finally
done and have a nice 3d spinning pyramid
don't forget to add comments to
everything you've written
to make sure you understand it and as
always
the source code is in the description
so now let's add a camera class to make
our lives easier
first start by creating a header file
named
camera.h preventing c plus plus from
opening it twice
and including all of the following for
the camera class we'll put everything
in the public section starting with the
victory for the position of the camera
a victory for the orientation aka
direction
of the camera and another vectory for
the up direction
now we'll also want the place to store
our width and height in
the last two variables will be the speed
of the camera
and the sensitivity of the camera when
looking around
i'll also make a very simple constructor
a matrix function which will create and
send the view and projection matrices to
the shader
and a function to handle all the inputs
now create a new cpp file named
camera.cpp
and include the camera header for the
constructor
we'll just assign values to the width
height and position
for the matrix function we first want to
initialize our matrices
and then we'll make use of the lookout
function
the lookout function takes the position
from which you want to look at something
the target you want to look at and the
up vector
in our case this would be the camera
position
the camera position plus our orientation
and the up vector the orientation vector
is always of length 1 and we'll be using
it as the vector we want to look at
so to say for the second matrix we'll
just do what we did in the last tutorial
then we'll simply export our matrix to
the vertex shader
good now let's go to the main function
and include the camera header
let's delete the old stuff including
this scaled uniform we had left over
from a few tutorials ago
and create a camera object named camera
giving it the width
and height variables in the position 002
now in the while loop delete the old
stuff again
and use the matrix function naming the
uniform cam matrix
the last thing we need to do before
getting back to what we had
last tutorial is to go to the vertex
shader and replace
all the previous uniforms with the cam
matrix uniform
now if you press run you should have the
exact same thing we had last time
except for the spinning pyramid and the
fact that everything
is now much cleaner in the main function
now let's just add some inputs to the
camera
i came up with these on my own so they
might not be the best
but they work just fine i'll start off
with the
wasd controls for which we'll simply
need to add or subtract from our
position
the speed times the orientation or the
right
vector which we get by doing a cross
product between the up vector and
orientation vector
make sure to use ifs and not else ifs
since we want to be able to modify
multiple of these at the same time in
order to go diagonally
now i'll just add space for going up and
control for going down
and make it so that when i hold shift my
speed increases
and when i release it my speed goes back
to normal
now include the inputs function in the
main while loop
and then if you boot up the program
you'll see that you can move about
though you can't really look around so
let's add some mouse controls
so i'll do an if and say that if i hold
down the left mouse button
i want my mouse to disappear and if i
release it
i want my mouse to appear again now i'll
create
two doubles for the x and y positions of
the mouse
and assign them values using the
function glfw get cursor position
plugging in the window and coordinate
references
then create two variables for the
rotation of our
orientation vector and make them equal
the sensitivity of the mouse
times one of the coordinates but make
sure to adjust
both coordinates since they normally
start in the top left corner
but we want them to start in the middle
of the screen and be
normalized so subtract from them half
the height or width
and then divide them by the height or
width
now in order to prevent the camera from
being able to do a barrel roll
we want to preemptively calculate the
new position
of the orientation around the x axis and
if the
angle between the new orientation and
the up or negative
up vectors is not less or equal than 5
degrees
then we assign the new orientation to
the orientation
then we also apply the y rotation to the
orientation
which we always apply since we want to
be able to spin around as much as we
want
at the end of the function we also want
to set the position of the mouse to the
center of the screen
so that the mouse doesn't end up
wandering in a corner and stopping us
from freely
moving the camera now if you start the
program
you'll notice that if we try to look
around our camera
jumps we can easily fix this by adding a
new variable to the header named first
click
and then in the inputs function in the
mouse part
we want to check if it's the first time
we press
the leftmost button since we've looked
around
if it is then we reset the mouse
position to the center
and make the first click variables false
the last thing we need to do is to make
the first click variable true
when releasing the leftmost button now
everything should be running smoothly
as always the source code is in the
description and don't forget to add
comments to everything to make sure you
understand it
so now we'll add some lighting to our
scene
first we'll slightly modify the camera
class so that we can efficiently use the
cam matrix on multiple object
and make sure the new camera functions
work properly in the main
function next we'll add a cube that will
serve as our light source
watch my previous tutorials if you don't
know how to do this especially my
coordinates video if you don't know what
the light pose
vector and light model matrix are for
then if you start out the program you
should see your main object in a small
cube that's completely white
so as you may have noticed in that nice
little game called
real life light can have multiple colors
usually it's
white and because of that it shows the
true colors of objects so to say
but if a light source is let's say red
then all objects will appear reddish
we can simulate this by multiplying the
color of an
object with the color of our light both
of which
are in rgb for example if our light has
the rgb values of
1 0 0 then when it's multiplied with the
color of the object
the green and blue parts will become 0
while the red part will stay the same
since it's multiplied by one this
simulates what happens in real life
as only the red color is reflected back
to us
even though the object is actually
orange
so let's make a vector called light
color and make it completely white
then we'll want to export it to both the
light fragmentator
and the fragment shader of our object in
the light one we'll simply use it as the
color of the object
while in the object shader will multiply
it by whatever you currently have in
your frag
color we are now able to simulate the
color of the light hitting the object
so next we'll want to simulate the
intensity of that light
you've probably noticed that the higher
the angle between a surface
and the source of light is the less
intense color
is on that surface this is the seen on a
sphere
where you can clearly see the gradient
of the intensity along the curve of the
sphere
in order to get this angle and calculate
the intensity
we'll need a position of the light which
we already have
and a way to know the slope of the
surface the traditional way of doing
this
is to represent the slope of the surface
by a normal vector
so so far we've had coordinates colors
and texture coordinates inside the
vertex now we'll also want to add
normals normals are unit vectors aka
vectors of length 1 that help us
calculate how light
should act on a certain object this can
be either perpendicular to the surface
of
one triangle called phase normals or
arranged in a different way such as
being perpendicular to the
plane created by all the adjacent
vertices
for example called vertex normals if you
go for the first option
you will get what's called flat shading
where all your triangles
are clearly visible if you go for the
second option
things look a lot smoother and nicer but
which one you choose depends on your
mesh
and on your artistic style since we have
a pyramid we'll go with the flat shading
since the smooth shading looks weird on
very angular geometric shapes such as
cubes or
pyramids now since the normals will be
different
on each side of the pyramid we won't be
able to fit
all of them in just five vertices like
we have here
we'll have to duplicate some vertices in
order to change their normals
so i'll just do that plugging in my
pre-calculated normals for
each face don't worry if some of your
normals are not
unit length it does not matter since we
can just normalize them in the shader
later
don't forget to also change your indices
the gel draw elements function
in case you haven't automated it like me
and
add a new attribute to the vao so now
for the vertex shader we'll
include the normal layout and also
export it to the fragment shader
along with the current position which
we'll use to calculate the direction
of light for consistency purposes i'll
also import the model matrix for the
pyramid
now in the fragment shader we import the
normal
and current position and the light
position uniform
then in the main function first
normalize the normal vector
and then get the light direction vector
by simply subtracting the current
position
from the light position and normalizing
it we now have the two vectors we need
the lighting we're implementing now is
called diffuse
lighting so i will create a float called
diffuse
then in order to make it such that the
larger the angle between the two
previously
calculated vectors the less intensity
the light
has we can simply use a dot product
between them
which is equal to the cosine of the
angle between them
since they are normalized now this can
also be
negative and since we don't want
negative colors
we'll take the maximum value between
this and
zero all that's left to do is to
multiply the diffuse float with the
color of the object
a texture in our case if you know boot
up the program
you will notice that we have some nice
lighting but
that the areas not touched by a light
are extremely
dark this is realistic in our case where
we only have
one object in or in a vacuum but
generally speaking it's not realistic a
slide will bounce from
other objects that are around onto our
object
this bouncing is expensive to calculate
and pretty
advanced so for now we'll simulate it by
simply giving a base value of brightness
this type of lighting is called ambient
lighting
so just create a float called ambient
and give it a value like 0.2
and then add it to the diffuse value in
the front color
boot up again and notice this looks a
bit better
the last type of lighting we have to add
in order to complete
our lighting algorithm which by the way
is called
phong shading is the specular light this
is dependent on the angle you look at an
object from so you'll need to import the
camera position into the fragment shader
first now create a float specular light
which will represent the maximum
intensity of this type of light
now we need a view direction which
should just be the composition
minus the current position normalized
and the other thing we need is the
direction of the reflection
which we can get by using the reflect
function
plugging in the negative direction of
the lighting
since we want the vector to be towards
the plane not away from it
and the normal then create a float spec
amount which will store how much
specular light we have at a certain
angle with our camera
so the larger the angle between the fuse
direction
and reflect direction is the weaker we
want the specular light to be
so just use a dot product like before
and take the max between this
and zero then we'll want to raise this
to a power
the higher the power is the more
point-like
and defined the specular light will be i
will go for a lower power such as
8. now create a float named specular and
multiply the specular light with the
spec
amount last thing to do is to add the
specular float to the diffuse
and ambient floats now you have some
nice decent lighting for your scene
don't forget to add comments to
everything you've written to make sure
you understand it
and as always the source code is in the
description
today i'll show you how to improve
specular lighting
with the use of specular maps i'll start
by slightly modifying the texture class
so that it's easier for us to
assign multiple textures to the same
shader
then i'll delete the pyramid we had and
simply create a flat plane
i'll also import this wood texture in
the specular map
you can find this in the description
i'll also assign the wood texture to the
plane
now as you can see the specular light
is just sort of flat areas that
shouldn't reflect
much light such as the cracks in the
wood still somewhat do so and the areas
that
should reflect a lot of light such as
the smooth tops of the wood
don't really do so in order to fix this
we can make use of something called a
specular map these types of maps are
black and white textures that tell the
program where specular light should
appear
and how strong it should be at that
point the whiter a pixel on the specular
map
is the more specular light you'll get
and the blacker a pixel is
the less specular light you'll get the
idea is really simple
so to implement it we must first import
a specular map into our program
make sure to import it using gl red not
gl rgba since it only has one color
channel
not four then simply export it to the
shader
and bind it in the main function now
import the texture in the shader
and in front color multiply its red
value by the specular light
and add that to the other texture which
is only multiplied by the diffuse and
ambient lighting now
that's it for the specular light now
i'll just change the value to make the
light
look better on the wood and if you then
boot up the program you should see that
the specular light
looks much better and it makes the whole
texture look
better overall as always the source code
is in the description
now let's take a look at different types
of light there are
three main types of light point
directional and spotlight
point lights illuminate the environment
in all directions
but the intensity of their light withers
as it gets further away
this is the type of light we've used
still now except we didn't
incorporate the loss of intensity so
let's quickly do that
first let's create a vector function
named point light and copy paste into it
all the things from the main function
and make frag color equal the output of
this function
so the intensity of light has an inverse
square relationship to distance in real
life
but in computer graphics we use a
somewhat more complicated equation to
better control the properties
of the light instead of having one over
distance squared we have
one over a quadratic equation with
respect to distance
this quadratic equation has two
constants a
the quadratic term and b the linear term
we can modify this to change how fast
the intensity dies out and how far the
light reaches
there is no general perfect number for
these constants
you just have to play with them and see
what works for your scene
just know that usually the numbers are
smaller than one if you want your light
to reach
somewhat far so to implement this we
first need a distance to the light
the distance is simply the length of the
vector that comes from subtracting
current position
from light position since we already use
this in our diffused lighting i'll
create a variable named light vector
so that we don't have to calculate it
twice now we can get a distance by
simply using the length function
lastly we just write out the equation
with the variables
and apply it to the specular and diffuse
lighting here are some examples of the
results i got using different constants
the second type of light is the
directional light this is usually
considered to be
so distant from your scene that the
light rays it emits
are essentially parallel to one another
just like the rays of the sun
this has no dimming and is actually the
easiest of the three to
implement we just need to copy paste
part of the code from the point light
and instead of calculating the light
direction based on some positions
we simply give it a constant y direction
as a normalized vector 3.
just note that it should point in the
opposite direction you want it to affect
due to the way i wrote the code here
so if you want the light to come from
above it should point
up not down and if you press run you'll
see everything is lit up
as it should be the last type of light
is the spotlight
the spotlight only lights a conic area
just like a flashlight or a disc clamp
for this we'll copy paste the point
light code again and begin by adding two
floats which will represent the cosine
values of
two angles the first angle is the angle
between the inner
cone and the direction of the light and
the second angle is the angle between
the outer cone and the direction of the
light
we make use of these two cones in order
to have a nice gradient between
darkness and light areas since if we
only made the use of
one cone we would just have a direct
cutoff
from light to darkness i wrote a cosine
value directly
in order to save computational power do
not write
the inner and outer cones in terms of
angles
since that will require extra
calculations and it will slow down the
program
now we need to calculate the angle
between the current part that is being
lit
in the central direction of the light
using a dot product
this will give us a cosine value which
is perfect to compare with our
own cosine values the last step is to
get the intensity of the current spot
which is done
using this formula make sure to also
clamp it between 0
and 1 so you don't get weird values and
lastly
just multiply the diffuse and the
specular lighting by the intensity
variable
start the program and you'll see that
the light is restricted to one
area don't forget to write comments for
everything you've written to make sure
you understand it
and as always the source code is in the
description
in this tutorial we'll wrap up all the
classes we've made till now and
a big part of the code in the main
function into a mesh class
that will also serve as a stepping stone
for importing models in a future
tutorial
first a rough definition of a mesh a
mesh is a data set that almost
always contains vertices often contains
indices
and sometimes contains textures as well
and
they are generally used to create 3d
models
so let's create a header file for the
class first we'll want to include the
string library
and then the vio ebo camera and texture
classes since we want the three of our
classes dependencies to
look like this now for the class itself
i'll declare
three vectors named vertices indices and
textures note that these are c plus
vectors and not glm vectors
we are using vectors instead of arrays
since we can't
know the size of our arrays so it's best
to keep things flexible in terms of
storage as you can see we get some
errors but don't worry we'll fix those
after we finish writing everything in
here
next we also want to store our vio since
we'll be initializing it using this
class
then for the constructor we'll simply
input the vertices indices and textures
and lastly we'll make a function draw
that will take in a shader and
a camera now for the errors let's go to
the vbo class
if you've been paying attention you
probably would have noticed that our
vertices vector contains a structure
named vertex but we don't have one so
far
so let's create one right here i'll
simply name the structure
vertex and give it three vectories for
the position normal in color
and then a vector for the texture
coordinates
having our data packed in such a
structure is
nicer than simply having all the data in
one array at least in my opinion don't
forget to also include the glm library
though
now we need to patch up the vbo class
constructor to
accept a vector of vertex structs
instead of an array
so let's also include the c plus plus
vector and since we're using vectors
instead of arrays
we can now also get rid of the size
input since we can calculate that
inside the class so in the vbo.cpp file
we can replace the size by
vertices.size times sizeofvertex
and for the data we just write vertices
dot
data if you return to the mesh class you
should have no more errors
now let's do what we did for the vbo
class to the ebo class as well
replacing the array with a vector now
for the main part
let's create the mesh.cpp file insert
writing the functions for this class
let's start with the constructor by
simply assigning the inputs to the
variables of the class
then copy paste the initialization of
the vao from the main function
and modify the variable's names slightly
and also the way the attributes are
stored
we want the position first then the
normals then the colors
and finally the texture coordinates
since we've modified this
we should go to the vertex shader and
rearrange the new order of the vertices
sections
properly and then do the same thing in
the fragment shader as well
it's not mandatory to keep them in this
specific order when
importing or exporting them but it just
looks
nicer to have them in the same order
everywhere
though it is important to have them in
the proper order
when choosing the layouts in the vertex
shader now let's continue with our mesh
class by
writing the draw function we'll start by
activating the shader
and biting the vao as usual now we'll
have to do something a bit more
complicated in order to properly load
the textures
since we won't always know how many
textures a mesh has
so let's create two unsigned integers
that are equal to zero
and are named num diffuse and num
specular
this will keep count of our two types of
textures then we want to go
through all the textures where we'll
have a temporary string
called num and another temporary string
called type which will store the type of
the current
texture the problem is that our textures
don't store their
type yet i mean they do it's just that
they store a different
kind of type in any case we'll want to
modify
our texture class by changing the type
variable to a constant character array
and so also the type of the input in the
constructor
then in the texture.cpp file we'll want
to make all the text type
equal gel texture 2d since 99
of the time that's what we'll be using
now let's go back to our mesh.cpp file
and create some checks we'll check if
the type is diffuse
and if it is make the num equal to a
string of num diffuse and then
increment it by 1. then we'll do the
same check for specular and
increment num specular now we want to
take care of the uniform
using our function text unit plugging in
the shader
then a c string composed of our type
plus num and the unit of our texture
then simply bind the texture so our
uniforms will be named diffuse 0
diffuse 1 diffuse 2 specular 0 etc
so in our fragment shader we want to
replace our text 0 uniform by
diffuse 0 and our text 1 uniform by
specular
0. then again go back to the mesh.tpp
file
and send our composition and count
matrix uniforms
and also write the gldraw elements
function
all that's left to do now is to modify
our main.cpp file
first we can delete all the includes and
only include our mesh class
then we'll have to modify the vertices
array and after that
in the main function make an array for
our textures as well
delete the vio initialization and create
vectors for
our vertices indices and textures using
the arrays from before
then create a mesh named floor with the
vectors we've just created
do the same for the light except we
don't have any textures on the light
so we'll just place the same textures as
a placeholder
in the while loop we can just delete all
the drawing stuff for the light and
floor and replace them with our draw
function
and finally we just need to get rid of
some of the deletes at the end of the
file
if you press run everything should now
be fine if you have any errors
go over the video again or check out the
source code in the description
as always you should add comments to
everything you've added to make sure you
understand what's happening
in this tutorial i'll show you how to
import 3d models into your opengl
application by building a very basic
importer this tutorial will also be
longer than usual
and only have visible results at the end
so please have patience and pay
attention to what i'm doing otherwise
you might end up with a chain of errors
by the end
a small note first as you may know when
it comes to storing images the industry
is pretty standardized with the use of
pngs and jpegs but when it comes to 3d
models
there are dozens upon dozens of file
formats many of which are proprietary
this diversity of file formats makes it
a lot more difficult to export and
import models from one program to
another
in the spirit of standardization i will
use the gltf file format for this
tutorial as it is made by
the same people who've made opengl the
chronos group
and it seems to be a promising file
format that could become the standard in
the future
i left a link to a nice article on this
by the developers of the godot engine
in the description now for the actual
tutorial gltf makes use of the json file
structure so the first thing we'll need
to do
is to install niels lofman's json
library from github to be able to parse
json files
that does it for the libraries now we
can create a header file for our model
class
a model being a group of meshes then
we'll make a constructor that will take
in the name of a file and the draw
function that will take in a shader and
a camera in the private section we'll
want to store the name of our file
a vector of bytes with all the data of
the model and a json object which i'll
explain more about in a moment
now for the model.cpp file let's read
the gltf file in the constructor using
the same function we use to read the
shaders
then we parse the text and store it in
the json variable
so json files work like dictionaries
within
dictionaries dictionaries have keys and
values associated to those keys
if you give a dictionary a key it will
point you to a certain value
this json object abstracts the gltf file
into such
structures so let's just store our file
and then equate our data variable to a
function
get data we want this function to get us
a vector of points from an external
binary data file
so let's create a string named bytestix
to hold the raw
text to get the location of the file we
can look at the buffers key which will
point us to an
array where we want to look at the first
element which will again be a dictionary
so we again want to use a key
this time the uri key this uri
gives us the name of a dot bin file
which contains the binary data then we
just get the text put it in a vector and
return it
so now that you have your first taste of
the json file
let's take a closer look at it the file
has dictionaries which contain
arrays of other dictionaries thus making
it a sort of tree
but it's not a very nice tree since many
branches will contain
indices that will point us to other
branches so things will get entangled
pretty quickly in order to avoid
confusion in such a situation
i like to start from the leaves and work
my way down to the root of the three
keep in mind that i will be taking some
shortcuts in the gldf file
since otherwise this importer would
become too complicated
with that out of the way here is a
simplified view of one of the main
branches of the tree
and the one we care most about at the
top we have our data that's stored in
the buffers
but to know which parts of it we should
read we need to take a look at the
buffer views
then again these will only tell us where
to look
not what to look for in order to know
what types of data types we are reading
we need to look at the accessors so
great the accessories tell us that we
are reading on
int or maybe a fake tree for example the
problem
is that they don't tell us what these
are used for
a vector iii could be both a position
and a normal
to find out which is which we need to
once again take a step back it's just
that this time we'll have to split in
two
if we look at the attributes then we
know which accessors
are part of which vertex attributes aka
positions normals texture coordinates
etc
if we look at the primitives we can find
the accessor of the
indices of our mesh keep in mind that
the attributes are pointed to by the
primitives
these also point to materials which
point to textures
but we'll ignore that since materials
often have pbr data
and since we haven't learned about that
yet we'll skip directly to the textures
ignoring the materials if we get back to
our main branch
the primitives are pointed to by the
meshes which are again pointed to by the
nodes and
lastly the scenes in our case we'll have
one scene
99 of the time so we can ignore those
and just focus
on the notes which will contain pointers
to all our meshes
don't worry if you don't fully
understand what i just went through
it's normal to not fully comprehend it
from the start you should get a better
idea of it when we write the code
so let's start with the leaves by
assuming we get an accessor node let's
declare a get floats function
in the get indices function then we'll
also want to declare
three functions that will take the array
vectors outputted by the get functions
and group them into glm vectors so
we'll first want the buffer view the
count the byte offset
and the type from the accessor notice
how i use the value function instead of
brackets to get the byte offset in
buffer view
the brackets will simply give you the
value of the key while the value
function will give you the value of the
key if it exists
otherwise it will give you the second
input these two parameters are not
always found in gltf files so i want a
backup value for them in case they do
not exist
while the other two always exist so i
don't need any backup
to see which of these are always found
and which or not check out the
specification
of gltf on github link in the
description
now using the index of the buffer view
we got we want to create a json variable
for the bufferview dictionary
from which we'll get the byte offset now
to explain
all the parameters we got the buffer
view index
simply pointed us to the correct buffer
view as mentioned
a second ago the count tells us how many
floats we have to get
the accessor byte offset tells us from
what index to look at the data
with respect to the beginning of the
buffer view and the byte offset
tells us where that buffer view starts
the reason we have two different
offsets is that sometimes two different
accessories may share the same buffer
view
for example we could have a vector3
buffer view
which is shared by a positions accessor
and a normal's accessor and finally the
type
tells us how we should group the floats
it can either be scalar
vector vector3 or vec4 using this type
we'll want to get the number of floats
per vertex then
in a for loop go over all the data we'll
store the bytes in a temporary array
which will then
use in the function memcpy to transform
the bytes into a float
which will then store in the variable
value and push it in the floatpick
vector at the end simply return the
floatvec
now i'll do the same thing for indices
except this time
we won't check the number since indices
are not stored in vertices
instead we'll check the data type of the
index itself
and according to that read it
differently from the data
the index can either have type 5125
which is an
unsigned integer type 5123
which is an unsigned short or type 5122
which is a short now for the grouping
functions we'll simply go over
all the floats in the float vector and
group them in their corresponding glm
vectors
really easy stuff using the get floats
function we'll be able to get
all the attributes of a vertex so the
next logical step would be to combine
those attributes in a vertex
so let's declare a function for that
which takes the vertices
normals and texture coordinates and
combines them into a vertex which will
be put in a c plus plus vector
very straightforward stuff notice that i
did not
include the colors in here since even
though we declared them in our vertex
they are actually very uncommon in 3d
models so we can ignore them
we now have the vertices and indices all
that's left for a complete mesh
is the textures but before we take care
of those we should first modify
our texture class a bit first we should
remove the last two inputs of the
constructor
since we'll atomize the first one and
the second one is
the same 99 of the time for the first
one
we'll simply check the number of color
channels a texture has
and assign a corresponding color type to
the texture
then for the second one we just replace
it everywhere with
gel unsigned white so now let's create a
get
textures function we want to skip
directly to the images key which will
give us an array of your eyes
here we loop over all of them while
keeping track of the unit of each
texture
then if the texture contains base color
in its name
it's a diffuse texture if the name
contains metallic roughness
we can somewhat use this texture as a
specular map
keep in mind that this way of checking
the type of a texture
is not ideal and may differ from model
to model
also the reason the metallic roughness
just sort of works for a specular map
is because it's something that's meant
for pbr the problem with this function
though is that it can load the same
texture multiple
times which we don't want to do since it
will use up a lot of ram
to prevent that we want to create two
variables
loaded text name and loaded text we'll
use loaded text name to determine
whether or not we've loaded a texture
and loaded text to store the textures
for all meshes to use
then in the function we'll add a skip
variable which will become true if the
texture we are currently trying to load
has the same name as a texture in loaded
text name
if it becomes true we don't load it
anymore instead
simply pushing an already loaded texture
to the textures vector
we can also replace the unit by the size
of the loaded text vector as well
this does it for our textures we don't
have all the elements needed for a mesh
so let's make a load mesh function that
will take in as an argument
the index of a mesh we want to load
we'll also want to create a meshes
vector to store
all the loaded meshes into so first we
want to get the indices
of all the accessors of the vertices
then we'll simply use our get floats and
group floats functions for the
attributes of the vertices
after that we assemble our vertices and
get our indices
and textures then we just create a mesh
with these three vectors
and push it to the meshes vector now we
can load multiple meshes by simply
iterating over them
the problem is that we don't know where
to place those meshes
so they will likely all be within one
another at the origin
in order to know where to place them and
how big they should be
we must extract the matrix
transformations from the gltf file
and we can't just get the matrix of each
mesh but must instead keep
track of what children each mesh has in
order to multiply the matrices of
each mesh together all the information
for the matrices and the relationship
between meshes
is in the nodes so let's create a
function named reverse node which takes
the index of a node
and the matrix making it half the
identity matrix as a default value
then let's also create vectors for
different types of transformation
matrices we have
translations which move the mesh
rotation switch rotated
scale switch change its size and
matrices which are a combination
of the offer mentioned but we can't know
if the first three will be used or just
a matrix
so we need to account for both we must
first modify our mesh class by adding
these transformations to the draw
function
as inputs with default values that don't
change
anything and then sending them to the
shader at the end of the function don't
forget to also create uniforms for these
transformations in the vertex shader
and multiply them like so i put a
negative sign
in front of the rotation matrix since
that's what i found to work
it might be a bug in my code or the fact
that glm and gltf use different rotation
standards aka
clockwise versus counter clockwise and
since we're in the vertex shader we also
need to rotate the texture coordinates
by 90 degrees which we can do with this
matrix
this again either has something to do
with the bug in the code or
different standards what's important is
that it works decently well
now for the function itself we'll want
to get a current node as
a json object and then extract the
transformations
if they exist notice how for the
rotation quaternion i get the indices
in the order 3 0 1 2 instead of 0 1 2
3. this is because gltf encodes
quaternions as
x y z w while glm uses them
as w x y z again just standardization
problems
now we want to combine all of these
transformations including the matrix we
get
us an input then we check if we have an
index to a mesh
and if we do we push all the
transformations and load the mesh
after that we check if the mesh has any
children and if it does we want to apply
this same function to all of them
while also giving them the current
matrix we have so this function is
recursive
and so we'll split along the parts of
the tree till it gets to all the nodes
now we can write this function in the
constructor and give it 0
as an input the last thing we need to do
is write our draw function
and that's it for the model class in the
main.cpp file we just have to include
the model class
and delete all the old mesh related
stuff then get some models
create a model object and draw it in the
main while loop here are some examples
of models i've been able to load in
i've left some models that should 100
work in the repository of this tutorial
on github so if you're getting some
errors check those models to see if you
have a problem with your code or the
model you're trying to load in again
keep in mind that this importer
is in no way complete and is in fact
very basic so don't expect to be able to
load in any model you find on the
internet i find that a decent amount of
models from sketchfab.com
work pretty well especially if they
don't have too many meshes
that's it for this tutorial it was a
really long one but also a very
rewarding one
if you ask me as always don't forget to
add comments to
everything you wrote to make sure you
understand it and the source code is in
the description
bye